la verrière va avoir son conseil
municipal pour les jeunes pour les 11 15
ans et si vous habitez la commune vous
avez peut-être vu cette affiche 9 et 10
janvier vont se tenir les élections pour
ce conseil municipal des jeunes bonsoir
béatrice goodman vous êtes le premier
adjointe à la démocratie locale les
premiers cmj à travers la france existe
depuis les années 70 un peu près alors
pourquoi aussi tard à la verrière même
si c'est très bien de mettre en place
alors juste une précision avant on a
décidé de reporter justement la date les
générations l'élection est illégale au
21 décembre ça laisse encore le temps à
chacun de se porter candidat voilà il ya
un petit peu plus de temps que je pense
que c'était important de préciser tout à
fait voilà alors ensuite moi m'a mise en
place pourquoi parce que la verrière est
une ville en pleine mutation une ville
qui est
qui est sur le chemin du développement
et qui va s'étendre qui commence déjà à
s'étendre et on a envie de donner la
parole aux jeunes a envie de les
intégrer complètement à ce que l'on va
mettre en place pour les années futures
parce que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont
les citoyens de demain que demain c'est
c'est très bientôt et que les pense le
maire et le conseil municipal pense que
ce que les jeunes en apporter est une
vraie richesse et qu'il est
qu'il est temps de se servir de cette
richesse là et de leur donner aussi a eu
la possibilité de s'investir sur des
projets et donc 11 15 ans le jeune
c'était trop jeune peut-être alors parce
que déjà il faut bien commencer quelque
part et que quand on veut qu'on soit des
projets à il ya quand même un certain
engagement
plus jeune ça faisait peut-être un petit
peu jeune et on al'envie quand même
d'avoir un cmj qui ait de véritables
projets qu'ils soient vraiment porteur
par contre si on l'espère très fortement
si notre cmj fonctionne alors dans un
deuxième temps on souhaiterait mettre en
place un conseil local de la jeunesse
par exemple qui s'adresserait à des
jeunes
des jeunes adultes entre 15 25 fours ne
s'est pas encore tout à fait déterminé
mais dans un deuxième temps où
s'adresserait des jeunes voilà là
plusieurs communes notamment sur saint
quentin en yvelines qui ont mis en place
on a vu quelques images d'un conseil
municipal de jeunes du côté de trappes
par exemple vous avez échangé avec les
autres communes pour voir comment ça
fonctionne et est ce que ça pouvait leur
apporter des idées de projets en fait
sur les communes avoisinantes pas encore
complètement mais on s'est affilié à la
neige qui est l'association nationale
des conseils de la jeunesse
donc on a fait des formations avec eux
on a rencontré d'autres élus on s'est
rendu au congrès d'un massage qui avait
lieu pendant les vacances de la
toussaint à l'île ce qui a permis de
rencontrer
d'autres conseils municipaux voir un
petit peu comment peut il fonctionner ce
que les jeunes ont pensé ce qu'ils en
retirent et comment est-ce qu'il
fonctionnait donc voilà il ya peu près
2000 conseils municipaux des jeunes en
france selon les chiffres justement de
l'organisme qu'il est qui les fédère que
vous avez mentionné vous êtes de à
travailler sur ce dossier oui vous pour
la démocratie locale est également l'élu
en charge de la jeunesse les libyens
c'est un projet qui portait donc par ces
de ces deux entités ces deux structures
nous avons rencontré l'autre élu nelly
du tube qui nous parle de l'importance
pour les jeunes de cette structure on
avait envie d'avoir un lieu pour pouvoir
les rencontrer pour échanger on les
connaît mais on a on sait où ils sont et
on sait qu'on en a 400 à peu près sur la
ville des jeunes de cet âge là
il y en a une centaine qui sont dans nos
centaines jeunes il y en a d'autres qui
sont à la maison de la musique et la
danse d'autres qui sont dans les
associations et pour pour les rencontrer
et pour
pour avoir un vrai chance c'est un peu
compliqué donc le cmj nous semble aussi
une bonne une bonne instance pour avoir
une idée réelle de ce que la jeunesse de
11-15 ans a besoin et envie
on espère qu'il y aura aussi un côté
éducatif pédagogique dans le dans le
sens de l'apprentissage à la citoyenneté
par le fait qu'ils mènent des actions
par le fait qu'ils vont aussi pouvoir
rencontrer des élus
ici mais à la région nationale etc
et
je pense que le fait que ce soit des
jeunes qui vont se pencher sur les
besoins des jeunes ont peut-être pouvoir
être plus
coller plus à la réalité de cette
jeunesse-là coller à la réalité de la
jeunesse ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui les
propositions de la ville en tout cas
était pas en adéquation avec les
attentes qui avait eu un discours un
dialogue qui étaient difficiles avec les
jeunes de la commune c'est pas que le
dialogue soit difficile avec les jeunes
de la commune c'est qu'on a envie qu'ils
aient une véritable place et leur faire
une véritable place et écouter ce qu'ils
ont à dire et les inciter à avoir des
projets pour leur ville et les inciter à
venir dessiner avec nous la ville
de demain et la ville tel qu'il le
souhaiterait ce qui veut pas dire qu'on
va faire exactement tout ce qu'ils
disent mais en tout cas on a vraiment le
souhait de les écouter ils peuvent se
manifester on va rappeler les dates les
élections seront bien les 9 et 10
janvier en revanche et le dépôt des
candidatures oui et qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 21 décembre au départ c'était
le 1er décembre ça laisse 20 jours
supplémentaires à tous les candidats qui
voudraient se manifester ensuite les
élections 9 et 10 janvier vous pouvez
soumettre vos candidatures auprès de la
municipalité si vous êtes entre 11 et 15
ans si vous êtes concerné par cette
tranche d'âge vous reviendrai bien sûr
sur le plateau va nous parler de ces
élections viendra voir également comment
ça se déroule dans cette commune de la
verrière merci en tout cas d'être venu
déjà nous en parler sur le plateau le
7-8 de ce 27 novembre eux se referme je
vous retrouve demain en direct à 18h
avec de nouveaux invités le point
complet sur l'actualité de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de versailles
du département des 6 mai